Oh Robert Klemke of mmq be alright we're
stirring it up stirring it up here
Robert here with your recap your recap
your your Cleveland Browns tweet for
everybody well you know I think that all
you see right now is hey the Browns are
considering Baker may feel the fronds
are considering Josh Allen or the Browns
are considering taking quarterback
they're one in four and I think that
it's it's a lot more simple than that I
think John Dorsey knows who he's going
to pick he's not telling anybody close
to him he's not telling his friends he's
not telling Scott McLuhan and I don't
think he's telling Hugh Jackson either
you know just from everything I've heard
about the way they've operated the last
few months he was on the hot seat he's
going to be coaching for his job
so John's not gonna be picking guys
according to Hughes mold for our
offensive players it's going to be
according to what john thinks is in the
best interest of the long-term success
of the football team and you know that's
not like those aren't observations that
generate headlines but I I don't think
it's as complicated as we're portraying
it but how do we know that he's not
telling his people like who's reporting
that that information if nobody else is
talking how do we know that you know
he's not giving any kind of information
to his his team well I think a lot of
people have reported that you know
people in the Browns organizations say
that they're considering so and so or or
so-and-so was in high consideration but
it would be an absolutely Jon's worst
interest to talk to his staff about his
plan at number one you know obviously
they have a board and they have people
that they like and they've people that
they've scouted that they feel are
worthy of the one-in-four picks but john
knows right now who he's picking it one
and it would make no sense for him to
tell anybody he has nothing to gain in
telling anybody in that organization
what his planet wanted well the
information I got was that it was Allen
and Baker Mayfield and that Sam Darnell
wasn't in the mix which surprised me
because if I'm the Browns I would take
Sam Darnell
this wasn't that somebody the person who
told me is not talking to somebody in
the browns organization in in management
you know I want to be careful here so it
and there's no agenda to it it was just
I was surprised as Sam Donald
was not in the mix that it was Baker
Mayfield in Josh Allen I think that was
the news that Mayfield was back in and
maybe Sam Donald was not so you know
whatever that information does to this
process moving forward I'm not sure but
that's what I was told I'd be shocked if
John hadn't already come to a decision
on the singleplayer that he's going to
pick you know more than two or three
weeks ago and and I and I and I don't
think that darn 'old is out of
consideration and I think that when
names like Josh Allen and Baker Mayfield
are thrown out there and and by the way
every single quarterback in the top for
the first round of this draft has been
tied to the Browns at one at some point
or another and I think that you know in
putting out information indirectly or
directly that says hey we're still
looking at this guy we're still
considering this guy you are enticing
teams like the Giants or the Jets at
three or the Broncos at five to look at
that and say hey maybe we do need to
trade up to one or maybe we do need to
trade up to two to get our guy because
now the Browns are talking about how
Josh Allen is it going to be available
beyond what are you hearing aid trades
would switch the trade to key or the
team or trade to keep an eye on I don't
think there's a way that Indianapolis
holds on to that six pick for a couple
reasons
there's going to be probably a fourth
quarterback available there you know
whether it's Rosen or Allen or Mayfield
orde Arnold and I think that the Buffalo
Bills are gonna be really motivated and
have the assets in the second round
especially to move up to that spot and
get their guy the other reason is
they're transitioning from a three-four
defense to a 4-3 with Matt Everett list
so they have four or five positions in
the front seven that they need to build
depth and find some quality starters
that right away or that's going to be a
disaster so I think that they're
probably the most motivated team to move
back and stockpile picks the other thing
that I found out Robert on Monday was
that the Giants ownership like say quan
barkley everybody else likes damned
arnold what do you make of that I could
see that I mean I think ownership
probably is looking at it from the
perspective we've got two or maybe even
three more good
years of Eli Manning as an above average
NFL starter and if we can bring in a
power running game like we had you know
ten years ago and maybe that's the
formula for success I think that Dave
gentlemen coming in probably see the
franchise passer in this draft and has
identified him and feels like that's the
move at number two because just for the
same reasons Eli Manning is a pretty
good player still and they're never
going to have the number two pick again
while he's a starter so if the guy you
like who's number one on your board is
still there at two I think that you make
you pick that quarterback hmm if your
guy is gone and I think you picked the
running back how many owners
aside from Jerry Jones do you think make
these picks yeah I mean I think it's a
case-by-case thing I don't think Jimmy
Haslam has made every first-round pick
but I know he made the Johnny Manziel he
shouldn't be allowed they should change
the code to the room and not allowed it
like who's there it's the owner what's
your name sorry we made the pack in the
Browns exams Arnold
so mostly how many how many owners I
think about I think it probably depends
on the position you know I think if your
team's in the market for a quarterback
almost every owner and in the league is
going to get involved and have some
input and really need to be convinced
that the person the general manager
thinks is the guy is actually the guy I
think that's the case around the league
more often than not if you're in the
first round and you're you're you know
you're about to pick a defensive tackle
I don't think that the GM really has to
break that down of the owner or the
owner is going to first in the room and
say no we're picking somebody else but I
think the high profile positions the
guys that you're going to end up
marketing in terms of you know the
endorsements and the apparel and all
that the guys are gonna be the face of
your franchise I I do think that that is
an ownership decision more than any
position where are you going to be on
draft night I'll be in Denver Thursday
at the Broncos facility and we'll be
writing about them if they make a splash
and then I've been writing this series
on Baker Mayfield so I'll be following
up Monday with whichever GM and head
coach ends up selecting him
Robert thank you we appreciate your time
on short notice and good luck tomorrow
night it's all good thank you that's
Robert Clem Co mm QB dot-com for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]